it is time for this week's sin city
chronicles august 16 1977. that was a
day that sent shock waves around the
world and certainly had an impact on las
vegas
good evening
elvis presley died today he was 42
apparently it was a heart attack
elvis only 42 years old when he passed
away the king left his mark on vegas
elvis performed at the international
hotel from 1969 to 1976.
all shows were a sellout tickets were
just 15 bucks and you got dinner with
the show elvis appeared in over 30
movies and recorded 600 songs
beatlemania took over las vegas in the
summer of 1964. the fab four they
performed two sold out shows at the
convention center on august 20th fans
actually lined the streets to catch a
glimpse of the band as they were
escorted from their rooms at the sahara
hotel over to the venue tickets for the
show started at two two dollars two
dollars to see the beatles that was the
only time they played as a group in las
vegas
[Music]
[Applause]
made his las vegas debut on august 21st
1974. that's when the jackson five
started a 14 night residency at the mgm
grand it was extra special because it
was the debut of the entire family
including siblings randy latoya and
janet alright everybody this next one
it's a house favorite
[Applause]
to sing along the spice girls spice
world tour was at the thomas and mack on
august 19 1998
the show sold out in less than 15
minutes but the girls were down the
member at the show ginger spice left the
group earlier in the year i was
heartbroken when that news
that news broke i was so sad that's your
sin city chronicles rocky over to you
hey any sin city's chronicles with spice
girls i'm here for